Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with the truth about the Islamic
Republic of Iran it's at war with the
United States only the Obama
Administration hasn't noticed the
Jerusalem Post recently quoted the
speaker of the Iranian Parliament Ali
larani warning the US Administration and
its House of Representatives and Senate
that injurious measures against the
nuclear agreement have reached such a
point that there is no way left for Iran
but to counteract as I show in my new
book The Complete infidels guide to Iran
Lara Johnny's bellicose language and
thinly Veiled Threat may have come as a
surprise to those who believe that
Barack Obama and John KY brought peace
for our time by means of the nuclear
deal but it was nothing new to those who
have been paying closer attention to
Iran than the Obama Administration has
when the nuclear deal was concluded aliw
bold a member of the kajar dynasty that
ruled Iran from 1785 to 1925 and a
longtime critic of the Islamic Republic
pointed out that the constitution of the
Islamic Republic proclaims the
ideological mission of jihad which it
defines as extending the sovereignty of
God's law throughout the world through
Iran's Army and the Islamic
revolutionary guard's core thus he said
to treat with the Islamic Republic over
the particulars of its Weaponry while
failing to address the very purpose of
its bellicosity is
delusional the so-called joint
comprehensive plan of action that's the
nuclear deal does nothing to change the
fact that in plain far sea Iran is
committed to World conquest by Islam
with its clerics as Warlords those to be
conquered include America the great
Satan Israel the little Satan and the
sunny Le Gulf
States now back in July 2005 the then
president of Iran Mahmud akad said
essentially the same thing he said the
message of the revolution is global and
is not restricted to a specific place or
time have no doubt Allah willing Islam
will conquer what it will conquer all
the mountaintops of the world no less an
authority than the Ayatollah Ki had said
from the beginning that the goals of the
Revolution were Global said Ki we shall
export our Revolution to the whole world
until the cry there is no God but Allah
resounds over the whole World there will
be struggle the Iranian politician Mosen
Rai once told a cheering Iranian crowd
we will build a force that will demolish
the enemies of Islam continue the path
of our great prophet Muhammad and raise
the flag of Islam in all corners of the
world there's even a neon sign in
tahan's mebad International Airport that
reads in English in future Islam will
destroy satanic sovereignty of the
West Iran's commitment to World Conquest
in the name of Islam and to the defeat
of America in particular precludes
lasting peace with the United States
according to the Islamic revolutionary
guards Corps Deputy Commander Hussein
salami on February 1st 2014 Israel and
the US can be defeated if only Muslim
Unity can be achieved salami said this
region is ideologically United by
similar faiths and common goals if these
goals can be merged and the Muslim
peoples are ideologically strategically
and politically United then Western and
particularly American political
breathing space will be restricted even
the Zionist regime which is America's
political military economic and security
Bridge head will have left no air to
breathe salami also issued this threat
whoever seeks to talk to our nation in
intimidating language we will not be
deterred by Geographic borders from
endangering their interests wherever
they may be we will be there as well we
will not confine the conflict to any
border we announce this loud and clear
on September 23rd 2015 2 months after
the Iran nuclear deal was finalized the
supreme leader of Iran Ayatollah Ali K
published an article entitled the idols
will be shattered Illustrated with a
drawing of the Statue of Liberty
shattered in pieces in it he declared
the idol of the soul the idol of Pride
and the idol of sexual lust the idol of
tyranny and subservience the idol of
global tyranny by which he meant the US
the idol of sloth and irresponsibility
and other Idols that shame the precious
human soul a plan that will Spring forth
from the depths of the heart will
shatter them in a Friday sermon in
September 2014 Senior Iran cleric huut
al-islam SED Muhammad sedi declared that
Iran's Islamic revolution heralded A New
World Order Iran's Islamic revolution he
said is part of the New World Order has
shaken the foundations of the order
imposed by the West on Muslim nations
this success is due to the efforts and
guidance of the late Imam Ki and those
of Ayatollah
K according to Iran's statun a news
agency the col Friday prayer leader
stressed that the custodians of the old
order with slogans such as Freedom
democracy and human rights has attracted
some people but that for a long time
westerners and Americans have based
their slogans on deceptive rhetoric they
seek to dominate the intellectual and
moral values of the world however they
have suffered a disadvantage because
their slogans have faded and people have
found them to be
false Freedom democracy and human rights
as far as Iran is concerned those are on
their way out Islam is coming in to
replace them courtesy of the Islamic
Republic of Iran the confrontation
between Iran and the US that the Iranian
mullah so desire has not been cancelled
by the nuclear deal on the contrary the
deal has made them Bolder and more
confrontational than ever I'm Robert
Spencer